another day in court for alexei navalny
this time around
a defamation hearing he is accused of
slandering a world war
ii veteran who appeared in this ad on
russian state channel rt
promoting last year's constitutional
changes
navalny had called those who took part
traitors
you can't see what i saw but couldn't
film in the courtroom
the 95 year old veteran beamed in via
video link
looking a little bewildered this is what
navalny had to say to those who'd put
him there
halfway through the old man felt unwell
and an ambulance was called but he
seemed to recover
the hearing will resume next friday the
whole process in there with the veteran
on zoom and these mysterious other
people
in the room around him seems so absurd
and stage managed
alexei navalny dealing with it in the
way that he does all the court processes
he's had to be a part of with a mix of
exasperation sarcasm and humor
also in moscow the eu's top man meeting
with russia's foreign minister
it must have been frosty the news
dropping a few hours later
that three european diplomats have been
expelled for participating in the
protests
over the last years our relations
have been marked by fundamental
differences
by lack of trust yes
it's true that they're not at their best
including due to one-sided illegitimate
restrictions which are introduced by the
eu
under trumped-up pretext
meanwhile videos of detainees cramped in
unsanitary cells in a center outside
moscow swept
through the russian web
[Applause]
still filled with protest spirit though
chanting all for one and one for all
in alexei navalny's honor
after two weekends of demonstrations and
more than 11 000 arrests
navalny's teams say that's it for now
but they're planning fresh protests for
later in the year
ahead of parliamentary elections in
september
dana magnay sky news moscow